I'm so glad you said that that is a
great question my brain just never know
like when I was a little kid there was
this song about the kilowatt plant high
hopes the high hopes hi I'm pie in the
sky hopes when you're ever feeling down
you know just remember that aunt we
pulled that kilowatt plant you know so
it's like no never you never can give up
on it now we get a one-way ticket in
life Frank and so we go on this life
adventure and so we do the most with our
ticket that we can this is a one-way
trip yeah so now yeah and so you look
around the world and you see you know
the happiness and the joy you know in
the spirit gone in human beings it's not
that it's just there no no it hasn't
stayed ignited it's like the pilot light
in the stove well you know is it for me
it's got to be there we saw
that never changes for me never changes
because hope isn't
again yeah yeah there is a time that I
said you know what you know this isn't
working for me you know this isn't
working for me and then I started
looking at what else am I gonna do you
know and then you have inspiration
tonight Star Wars your app installations
like the peanuts you have inspirations
like you know Spielberg we have
inspirations like Madonna you know you
have inspirations like let's say a
community center of minority kids in the
last minute you know you have things
around you know and you also have the
little girl in children's hospital
suffering from brain cancer that may not
even be able to graduate from school may
not be able to have a family of her own
and then you start to put things in
perspective you start to go away wow the
kitten the hummingbird the ladybug and
the old lady and the elevator with me
all are under the one son for that one
day it's how you use it right
you